niños y adultos mirando el retorno al
mar de 500 tortugas en esta Playa del
Pacífico mexicano hace un poco más de 30
años que se realizan operaciones de
liberación de tortugas marinas todo
empieza en el sitio de admiración donde
se monitorea de manera permanente y se
cuida a los nidos en una lucha para
conservar el hábitat natural de las
especies cuando incubamos En la
temporada de Julio a diciembre que se
llena un Corral Pero se tiene que pasar
al siguiente Corral para que se pueda
seguir el seguimiento y no perder Ahora
sí ningún ningún este nido en las playas
para poder recuperarlo y traerlo a los
por las incubaciones los miembros de la
organización se dicen felices con los
resultados entre otras cosas el aumento
de la llegada de hembras anidadoras
gracias a la consolidación de cuatro
campamentos de tortuga en Chiapas pero a
pesar de que existe un trabajo de
concientización los biólogos e
investigadores siguen luchando contra
los saqueadores dividos tal como la
crisis climática al parecer a las
tortugas que pareciera que no son tan
importantes sin embargo sí lo son este
vamos a desencadenar un desequilibrio
ecológico aparte con estos efectos del
cambio climático que se están dando del
aumento de las temperaturas como sabemos
los reptiles este su sexo está
determinado por la temperatura
las especies que arriban a estas playas
del océano Pacífico corresponden a
cuatro grupos entre ellas está en la
tortuga verde negra Carey golfina y laúd
todas en peligro de extinción